à laval deux usagers sur trois craignent
de prendre les transports en commun la
plupart du monde hip hop avrillé et
touche à tout et non c'est ça qui me
fait peur pas de couvre 2 m un sondage
de la stl a aussi démontré que les
répondants ont peur que la distanciation
ne soit pas respecté face à ces
préoccupations
la société a lancé sur son site internet
une plateforme informatique
une façon pour les usagers de planifier
leur trajet est de savoir combien de
passagers sont à bord du bus à chacun
des arrêts c'est un outil qui permet
d'apprécier le niveau d'occupation de 2
dans l'autobus à l'avance pour ferme et
aux gens de prendre des voyages dans
lesquelles sont à l'aise depuis des
années la stl sait exactement combien
d'usagers prennent le bus à eau de
chacune des portes vous avez
effectivement des lecteurs infrarouge
pour calculer le nombre de passagers
chaque jour
ces données sont transmises à des
serveurs leur compilation a permis de
lancer cette plateforme
ça pourrait permettre aux gens de
d'anticiper leurs déplacements peut-être
plus rapidement je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose que les gens soient informés
sur nombre de gens qui dans les bus à
l'automne le nombre d'usagers pourrait
augmenter
l'outil sera t'il encore fiable les gens
vont pouvoir quel que soit le niveau
après 6 ce qui est ce niveau et ensuite
choisir de se déplacer à cette heure-là
plus tard au plus tôt le système est
perfectible nous dit la stl qui envisage
même une application avec des données en
temps réel la stm travaille sur son
propre outil prévu à la fin de l'été à
longueuil
l'idée fait son chemin mais son
implantation n'est pas prévu à court
terme si has no cry et radio-canada mort
allah